um so yeah i'll be talking about polar
codes
so the general setting that we'll deal
with is um the familiar setting of
channel coding in which we have a
message that we want to transmit over a
noisy channel
and
we use error correcting codes to encode
a message into a larger space
okay so
kind of the fundamental theorem
is shannon's theorem which tells us that
for any discrete memoryless channel
there's an associated constant
known as the channel capacity such that
we can communicate
at any rate that's below the capacity
and conversely for any rate
that is above the capacity
we have to incur
some probability of miscommunication
so
suppose we have a rate r that is epsilon
less than the capacity
um we're going to say that the gap to
capacity is epsilon so this is the
terminology we will be using
and the challenge that coding theorists
care about is actually finding error
correcting codes that achieve
arbitrarily small gap capacity
okay so just to kind of
set the bar um if we take random codes
it turns out that shannon's theorem
shows us
if we want a gap of roughly epsilon
it suffices to take a random code of
block length n which is
which scales quadratically in one over
the gap
but of course we want to know actual
explicit codes that achieve capacity so
that will sort of be the guiding
question for the remaining of the
remainder of the talk
so let's just formalize the problem
so we're given a discrete memoryless
channel w
and we're given a parameter epsilon
which is the gap to capacity that we
want to target
so the problem is as follows we want to
construct an explicit error correcting
code with
an encoding and decoding map that is
explicit
such that the rate is within epsilon of
capacity
we also want the block length to scale
uh polynomially and one over the gap so
this is kind of the focus of what we're
going to prove later on
we also
want our code to be efficient so i
should be able to compute the encoding
and decoding functions in
a
time that is also polynomial
and finally we want the communication
scheme to be reliable so the probability
of miscommunication should go to zero
asymptotically
okay so before we talk about the
contribution of this work let's just
look at some of the codes that are out
there that either achieve capacity or
get close to capacity
so
sort of the classic example is
concatenated codes which are known to
achieve arbitrarily small graphic
capacity
unfortunately the decoding complexity
for the range of parameters that we care
about
scales exponentially in one over the f
squared so this is not very practical
for
achieving capacity
um we also have ldbc codes which are
widely used
but we only know that they approach
that they approach capacity for the
erasure channel
turbo codes also
are widely used in practice but again we
don't have any theoretical results that
show
arbitrarily uh
closeness to capacity
there's been some recent work with
spatially coupled ldpc codes and these
are actually known to achieve capacity
with the
arbitrarily small gap
but there's still questions about how
the block length scales
and finally
the focus of our attack will be polar
codes which are known to achieve
capacity for
symmetric channels
okay so i just want to
state that polar codes are the first
known construction
um at least explicit construction that
achieves capacity with the guarantees
that we listed in the
slide on the problem formulation
so in particular the rate gets
arbitrarily close to capacity
um the encoder and decoder complexity is
n log n which is polynomial in the block
then
and
for polar codes over binary alphabets
there are a couple of works that show
how fast we get a convergence to
capacity
in particular
there's some constancy such that it
suffices to take a block length
of one over epsilon to the c
um
expander codes
yeah i mean there's some question about
like if you if you want to achieve uh
close to capacity
how that works we can take it offline oh
because you still need some i mean
construction to give you some error
correcting radius but they don't uh you
know shift and if you do any
concatenation then the inner code is
still there there's still exponential
complexity yeah it's even the one in
epsilon squared just like you know about
their constant size
no no but they get close to capacity
right so even for concatenated codes the
general setting
um the the decoding time is
fast but for the range of parameters we
want to get close to capacity the
scaling is exponential
okay so the question you want to ask is
what about polar codes over non-binary
alphabets
so the main contribution of this work is
to extend the work of guru swamisha
which yields with binary codes uh two
qary polar codes for
prime q
um so in particular we show that the
rate um to get an epsilon gap to
capacity it surprises to take a block
like this polynomial the only difference
this time is that the constant we get is
dependent on q
okay so as a consequence uh these are
the first
explicitly
um
efficiently encodeable decodable codes
that we know and as far as i know the
only construction that we know so far
with the theoretical guarantees for
speed of convergence
let's see go as q gets bigger
uh so right now in our analysis it's
polynomial in q
so it's
for those of you who care about the
practical considerations it's
quite bad
um but that's part of our analysis it's
quite possible that the concept should
not depend on you but
we don't know that at the moment
and the
sort of technical ingredient that we use
to establish our theorem is an entropic
increase in equality over prime alphabet
so the original analysis for analyzing
the convergence capacity used martingale
convergence theorems and so we bypass
this
with a entropic increase inequality so
i'll talk a bit about that
later in the talk
um so i should just say that in the work
of guru swami shah the entropic increase
in equality was implicit in their work
um
but for higher q there's actually some
technical difficulties that arise so
it's
not really a simple extension of the q
equals two views
again i'll touch on this later
okay so let's just kind of recall
how polar codes work
so there have been a couple of talks
during this workshop which describe the
construction and how to decode polar
codes
we won't really have time to talk about
that in detail but uh
let's just go over sort of the main
points you need to know
so first of all i want to
restrict our attention to symmetric uh
discrete memoryless channels w
and i'll find it convenient to talk
about
you know to think of channels as kind of
correlated random variables x and y
where you can think of x as
the input of the channel and y is the
output
and again we'll be dealing with channels
where
the input x is
supported on an alphabet size of q
so i'm going to define this notation
h of w
for channel w
to be simply the conditional entropy of
the input x
given y
and
you know assuming that
so because this is symmetric uh channel
assuming that x is uniform on its input
this is equal to
uh one minus the channel capacity so one
note that i want to make is
that
the entropies that we're going to work
with are actually normalized so recall
that
our variables are on an alphabet of size
q so entropies are distributed between 0
and log q
so we're going to actually normalize by
log q because we want the entropies to
lie between 0 and 1.
so for the remainder of the talk just
assume that whenever i use h
it's actually normalized by log q
so is there any questions about that
okay so
the setup is as follows we're gonna
take n copies of our input x
uh denoted x naught 3x n minus one
and we're going to run this through
basically n instances of our channel w
and we get
output y naught through
y n minus one
and now the idea is that we have some
polarizing matrix pn
which takes our x's to use
right and
the thing to note is that the
conditional entropy
of the use given the ys
is precisely the entropy of the x's
given the y's and this is simply because
we have
an invertible map that goes between the
two
and this is also
the
um
entropy of the channel times the number
of copies we have
okay so we're going to define these
intermediate channels so
remember we've taken n copies of w and
we're going to split this into
n new channels
that we denote w zero through w n minus
one
and the ith channel is basically going
to be
you can look at it as taking input ui
and outputting
the previous use as well as all the
outputs of the channel
so these are our new channels
and it's not too hard to see that
by the chain rule for entropies
if we add
the entropies of these channels
it's going to
be equal to the total for the n copies
of w that we started with so we're
preserving
the sum of the entropies
okay so i've just kind of
formulated that
on the next line
so the main property that we want from
our map p of n
is that
as n goes to infinity
we want all of these h values to go to
either zero or one so if we have any
interval that's
sort of in the middle
there should be a vanishing probability
that
one of these lies in the middle so
that's the property we want
and then as you may recall
so
once we have n large enough
we have the set of
channels whose entropy is close to zero
and the ones close to one
and since we know what the total entropy
is
we know that roughly the fraction of
channels that are close to zero
will be
close to the
channel capacity of w
the normalized channel capacity
so
our code can
you know so we've taken n copies of w
and we've split them into channels which
are all
either close to perfect channels or
close to completely useless channels
and we use the the channels that are
close to perfect
okay so let's just take an example for
two by two matrices
so
again we have a channel w w over a qre
input
and
let's look at the following map which is
the
original map that erican considered
so
if u naught is the sum of x naught and
x1 and u1 is the sum of x1
this is going to achieve polarization
which i'll describe
so in particular if we take
two copies x naught y naught and x one y
one
um we can
take two copies of our channel and split
them into
uh w minus and w plus
and i guess these are the
only equations that we need to know so
if we um
sum the entropies of w minus and w plus
that preserves what we started with but
on the other hand we
get a split between
the
channels that we have obtained
okay so
using this
g2 matrix um we can
kind of recursively do this for
increasing block length n so we just
kind of
we have n equals two to the little n
then we can kind of
do little n layers of this
this two by two matrix
so i'm not going to go into too many
details but basically what we need to
know is
we need a handle on the channels that we
obtain after
splitting end copies of w
and
what we need to know is
that okay so in the two by two case we
started with two copies of w
and we constructed w minus and w plus so
that's
sort of going down one step in this tree
now what i can do is kind of repeat this
with the
w minus and w plus channels so we go
down another layer
we get four channels and we can continue
this for
little n steps
so at the leaf
we get two to the n channels and so
these are these are going to be
precisely the channels that
we obtain after
using the polarizing matrix
so are there any questions on that so
far
steve
and the decoding probability that you
get as a function of capital five
capacity for the binary case
um for the binary case the decoding
probability is roughly exponential in
negative square root of the block length
as a function
and n is uh one over epsilon to the uh
uh well the actual constant we don't
know but you can get something around
four
okay so
okay so we have this tree of channels
and remember the channels of interest
are the ones at the bottom level
and our goal is to show
that all of these channels are
close to zero or one
in entropy value
okay so the initial analysis that was
used
some years ago
was the use of martingale convergence
theorems
so if we in particular you can think of
a random walk which starts at the top
node
and at each step we
either go to the left or to the right
with probability half
so
so we got w minus or w plus each with
probability of half and you can think of
just
going for n steps until you reach the
bottom
so for the j level
we can consider the
random value random variable which tells
you the entropy so if h j is the entropy
at the j level
the sequence of uh h naught h1 forms a
martingale
and moreover the martingale is bounded
and we can also
consider the fixed points of
evolution so in particular
for zero and one the channel evolution
is fixed this corresponds to w being
either a perfect channel or a
completely useless channel
so in particular the martingale
convergence theorem tells us that we
converge to a zero one valued random
variable
and this gives us the
convergence to capacity
unfortunately the fact that we use
martingale convergence
means that we know nothing about the
speed of convergence so
to sort of get guarantees on the block
length we need some other analysis
technique that
avoids smarting bills
so our solution is to argue
directly about the entropies of these
channels as we go down the tree
okay so
the key technical ingredient that
saves us from the
appeal to martingales
is this entropic inequality
so again
channel is going to be w with you can
think of input x and output y
so
what we really want to do is quantify
how much the
channel splits when we go to w minus and
w plus
so remember we start
you know one level of the evolution we
start with two copies of w and we split
into w minus and w plus we want to know
how much does w minus actually deviate
from w
and it turns out that
what we need is a
linear increase in
h times one minus h
so you can kind of unroll the definition
of these h of w's in each of w minuses
and the theorem we need is basically
that
if we have these correlated random
variables where x is supported on an
alphabet of size q
we can take
two independent copies
and we get the following inequality
so just to kind of give you an idea of
what was known
um this inequality was known with
the right-hand side being a quadratic
term
however this is
not sufficient to get a block length
which is polynomial so we really need a
linear increase
okay so before i talk about the entropic
inequality i just want to say
why does this give us the convergence
result that we need
so
in particular the entropic inequality
allows us to argue as follows so
if we
take a look at a channel w
we look at h of w times one minus h of w
and look at the square root of that
what we can argue is that each time we
go down
one level of the tree the expected value
of this goes down by a
constant factor
so in particular what that tells us is
that if we go for roughly log of 1 over
epsilon recursive steps
um
the probability that you have
an entropy that's close to zero
will be roughly
i of w the normalized channel capacity
okay so
okay so
this we call rough polarization we've
shown that for roughly log of one over
epsilon steps
we end up with um roughly i of w
entropies that are close to zero
but unfortunately this is not good
enough for us
we actually need to show
that these entropies are not just less
than epsilon but actually
much less than one in one over the block
length
and the reason we need this is that
these h events actually
uh when we're doing the decoding process
they give us an estimate of
the probability that we decode a bit
incorrectly
so in the end if we want to argue that
the decoding probability is low we need
to do a union bound over
close to n
items so
to survive the union bound we need
a fraction that's much less than one
over n so the idea is that
you can kind of do this rough
polarization
so i've denoted the entropies that are
smaller than epsilon in green so these
are your good entropies
and the ones that are bigger are red so
these are the bad ones
and the idea is that we completely give
up on the bad nodes
and starting from one of these
good nodes we can
drive down the entropies
even faster
so
i'm not going to show you the details
but it turns out that
if you
sort of start from one of these nodes
then most of the paths are actually good
and
will polarize fairly quickly
and we analyze
the decrease of the entropy using uh
something called the battery parameter
this is basically an estimate of
it's a parameter that allows us to
estimate the entropy you can think of it
as
um
dealing with the entropies directly is
kind of difficult so
we use this kind of as a proxy
to analyze the entropies so i'm not
going to go through the details but you
can just trust me on this one
okay so now let's go back to the entropy
inequality now that i've hopefully
convinced you that this is the
key item that we need
so
for the binary case
the
inequality is as follows
and it turns out that if we fix this uh
conditional entropy x given y
we have a very simple characterization
for what minimizes the left hand side
so
in particular it turns out that
the sort of minimum distribution
for the left-hand side
happens when
each of these
conditional entropies when you fix a
particular y
are equal
and what this effectively does for us is
allows us to
remove all these
conditional
entropies and just argue about
unconditional entropy so
really we just need this simple
inequality
for unconditional binary random
variables
and
since it's a binary variable
the entropy is characterized completely
by
say
the weight on a particular element say
zero
so we can actually just explicitly
compute this and it's uh quite easy to
show
so how am i doing that then okay
so
the problem with the qari case is that
we don't know any easy characterization
for this extremal case so here
really the extremal case told us that we
can pass to an unconditional inequality
but for the q area case this
this characterization seems false
so this
makes the qre case much harder
um so i'm gonna
skip through this it's kind of technical
okay so
okay so now i've shown you that um
so i haven't gone through the proof but
uh
it's kind of technical but we
established the inequality for prime q
so you may wonder the question what
about non-prime q so why do we need
primality of q
um so
it turns out that in general this
inequality is not true
in fact polarization itself does not
hold for non-prime q
and the reason is that suppose x
suppose x is a
random variable on
q elements if q is not prime then we
have a additive subgroup
of
0 1 through q
and basically i can take a counter
example in which x is supported on the
subgroup so if i take two copies of
x and add them we will always stay
inside the subgroup
so
if x is uniform on the subgroup then
we're basically not going to get any
increase on the left side
so this is kind of the reason that you
cannot expect something like this to
hold for an on-prem queue
however you can still
construct capacity achieving codes for
non-prime queue
and what you can kind of do is
factor q into primes and you can take
polar codes over these prime alphabets
and kind of piece them together so this
is uh
what we call multi-level code
construction and this is uh this has
appeared in a couple of papers
and then you can
do a similar successive cancellation
decoding
which i'm not going to go through for
this talk
okay so
conclusion
uh polar codes have polynomial gap
capacity
for alphabets of prime size
and we can also use these to construct
codes for non-prime
alphabets and it should be noted i
didn't really talk about source coding
but the construction we have works for
source coding as well
so that's lossless data compression
so the main open question that i see is
pinning down this optimal value of c
um so i mentioned in response to the
earlier question that in our analysis c
is dependent on the prime q
um however you know what is the true
constancy um in particular
as q goes to infinity can we show that
c approaches two which is kind of the
constant you get from random coding
and then there's also the entropic
inequality which is of independent
interest
and you can pin down what the
linear increase factor is
in the entropic inequality
um unfortunately
it's not too hard to show that you
cannot get a constant that's better than
one over log q
so in particular
if you're trying to show
a constant c here which is
you know maybe
you know approaches a constant as q goes
to infinity this is not going to be
possible with our entropic inequality
approach because
simply we get a bad dependence on alpha
and alpha currently is polynomial in q
but
okay and finally i should just mention
that the entropic inequality you can
view it as a
entropic version of a sunset inequality
so in additive combinatorics
there are a number of inequalities of
the flavor where you have a particular
set
and you have some additive structure and
you add it to itself and you want to
kind of analyze how
how much it grows
so here the entropic analog is you have
an you have a random variable
with certain entropy and then you sort
of take two copies add them together and
analyze the entropy so really you can
view this as a sum set inequality for
in the entropy setting so there's
a lot of connections there to explore
which i have not really
dealt with so far
and then finally the question of you
know we dealt with this particular
polarizing map the 1101 matrix
what can you say for other polarizing
maps do you still get the polynomial
convergence
so that would be interesting to see
and
that's all i have for today thanks
uh why does why do you say it doesn't
work for lossy sources
yeah i mean you can you can do it for a
lossy as well
yes so
are you just using the quality map where
the matrix is the one one one matrix
right right
um
this this thing for q it seems like um
if you wanted to have a different
dependence on q you might change that
matrix
so each time you're only adding so it's
going to take a long time to mix things
right you multiply by two
then you might see a much faster mixing
so if the coefficients are like one two
one
yeah i mean i think that would be
interesting to see what happens for
other maps um
but ultimately you would need some kind
of uh
you know an entropic inequality that
deals with coefficients
in the case when q is the power of a
prime
oh let's say
it has an additive group right is it
clear that there is no polarizing map
which will give you the required
inequality um so if you just consider
linear maps
you're going to run into the same
problem it's not just the 1101 map
so you really for prime powers you need
some kind of non-linearity
um so there's
uh some work
uh
primitive element isn't there work on
polarity for gf
for prime power so you put the primitive
element
it won't but
you can change what is the body by
polarization that's like that's easier
if you don't insist that you get perfect
versus junk
structure
so there is a work i believe teletars on
it
in which
you can look at a similar map as the 1 1
0 1 but instead of u 1 equal to x 1 you
can do some kind of permutation of the
distribution of x 1.
so
you can think of x as
having different weights on your q
elements and you can kind of permute
them so that's a non-linear step but in
general you need some kind of
non-linearity
i have a naive question yeah is is two
of the best you could possibly get
even with big q yes
oh that's
i mean so i don't know of a lower round
for
this particular pool
that comes from general that's just from
the shannon
but it's important to note that we don't
um
so for q equals two we know a lower
bouncy which is
roughly 3.5 i think
but for general q um
i'm not aware of any
lower bound in this argument
but the general sequels too follows from
just general principles of shadows
the c goes up as q goes up is that right
right in our particular analysis we show
this for an increasing function
but that might just be
an artifact of an our analysis
so in particular maybe if q
increases enough you start to decrease
okay good thank you very much